a new photo of a now bearded Dylan
O'Brien has surfaced and fans
collectively sigh in relief this is the
first image we've seen of Dylan since he
was hospitalized in March after
reportedly being run over by a car while
filming Maze Runner the death cure he
has not given any updates or posted on
social media
his Teen Wolf co-stars recently told
idea that Dylan and his family
appreciate the outpouring of love and
concern I think he's doing a really he's
well and we'll see him soon I hope so I
don't like to speak on behalf of other
people but but from we've spoken and he
seems okay good fans just want to know
if he's doing okay Teen Wolf forever
when it comes to stuff like that you
know that's obviously him and anyone
that's close to him you know prerogative
to stay if and when how things are I
know he's okay which is the important
thing so if people have been concerned
should they appreciate the concern is
that what he's doing okay he's the
greatest guy absolute greatest guy most
contagious laughs I did it yeah okay
with him and all he talked about
baseball for 15 minute oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah well that's all that's out
Dylan and I kind of have a connected as
friends in the first place was that the
the test and you know he's a massive
Mets fan and my roommate in college was
like Davison so he knew I liked when I
was in the my league system and so he
was like you know I was he supposed to
save the Mets and and all its all that
stuff so that's no we connect